i've realized that
it's scary when you find a thing that
you're going to fully commit yourself to
the pursuit of especially if it's
excellence that you're going after
because there's no more room for your
inadequacies to hide
anymore you can't decide to change
direction and do something else if
things get tough there's no more ejector
seat right i've committed to this this
is my thing and this is one of your
rules you know commit to something as
yeah commit to at least one thing as
hard as you can yeah and see what
happens yeah precisely aim yourself in
one direction and
i had to rule with my clients because
you know you might say well i've gone
halfway down this path and i found out
it's wrong so how do you distinguish
that from just giving up well that's a
really hard question right it's it's a
moral hazard
because it's inappropriate to continue
in a direction you now realize to be
wrong but it's also inappropriate to
give up and
use that rationalization as an excuse
and how do you distinguish especially
seeing as we're not transparent to
ourselves well right exactly so that is
genuinely a moral hazard so one of the
principles that i tried to abide by in
my therapeutic discussions was you can
change course as long as the next thing
you do is equally or more difficult
because that's a check against just
giving up
so
you want to discipline yourself so you
can get yourself organized so that you
can go in a particular direction so that
when you find the right direction you
can really go in that direction and that
does require an apprenticeship of sorts
and it it might not matter in some sense
exactly what the apprenticeship is
as long as
it is rigorous
right and so
that's sort of a bridge between moral
relativism and moral absolutism
there's lots of games you can play
it's not that obvious a prairie which is
the best game so that's kind of a
morally relative stance there's multiple
playable
games
but then the absolute is yeah but you
have to play one of them you have to
learn to play one of them you have to
become an expert at at least one of them
and then that's not a relative
proposition and i i believe that's true
that seems to me to be the case so you
want to commit to something
and then you you have when you commit to
something you
require yourself to
bring all of your disparate disparate
components
moving in a single direction united in a
single direction so it's a unifying it's
a unifying act
and then once having been unified
well then you can bring that unity to
bear on a variety of different tasks but
you have to bring it together first
so and that that makes sense
developmentally you see children
start out
as a disparate bundle of motivations and
emotions sort of warring with one
another
and then they can integrate that into
single games that they can play with
themselves
and then they integrate that with games
they start to play with other people and
all of that is integration it's not
subjugation it's not repression
not if it's a good game it's integration
you want to get integrated because then
you have
all the horses that are pulling your
chariot pulling in the same direction
and you're much more likely to get to
where you want to go then and also much
more likely to specify a good place to
go
so
that's another re that's something else
conservatives have to teach young people
which is well get yourself disciplined
well why
well not so you're a slave but so that
you could be a master
to use a terminology that you're not
supposed to use anymore but you know
this is in relationship to yourself
not to others
so
yeah and to begin with you have to
accept an external master
because
you just don't have the wisdom to do
that for yourself or the ability or the
opportunity often
everybody knows this you know they feel
bad when they
they decide they're going to put get
themselves in good shape and go to the
gym and lasts like three
days attempts yeah
and then
no one's happy about the fact that they
quit
and they berate themselves for it and we
know that we need to go through a
disciplinary process we need to
subjugate ourselves to a disciplinary
process that's part of the problem with
the constant harping about the you know
oppressive patriarchy
you need a disciplinary process
so
well that's just oppression and slavery
it's like no it's not
no more than a game is
not a good game good game isn't
oppression and slavery we saw
was it being on time being punctual was
laid at the feet of some
oppressors yeah obviously
yeah that's utterly
imbecilic
i mean even at a scientific level
there's no that's trait
conscientiousness by the way to be
punctual part of orderliness and
dutifulness
industriousness there's no evidence
whatsoever that that varies by ethnicity
or race
or supremacy yeah or supremacy and it
there is evidence that if you are like
that you are more supreme well you are
more likely to succeed it's one it is
the most determinating
it's the most
it's the most potent personality
predictor of
success in algorithmic domains
managerial administrative domains
so hard work works
and in fact the degree to which hard
work works is actually the one metric
of the
health of a society
the higher the correlation between
conscientiousness and outcome the
healthier the society well obviously why
well
you want the bulk of the credit to go to
the people who are the most productive i
mean
not because not even in some sense
because they deserve it
because what does deserve mean exactly
it is because they deserve it but
that's a black box that word it's
because
if you want them to keep making stuff
you have to do that
and you want them to because well or
what you don't want food
you don't want shelter
why would you not reward the people who
provide it differentially
just your own even your own narrow
self-interest would require that
so
talking about committing to one thing
and the inevitable pain of
then not being an easy get out anymore
i've decided that this is my thing i'm
going after it yeah it's useful to stick
a temporal parameter or an
accomplishment parameter on it that's
one of the reasons
for six months yeah yeah well
i'm going to get this degree no matter
what
well it's a time limit it's not your
whole life but you're committed to that
and then you do box yourself in it's
like well i'm in this box i have to make
the best of it that's right
you're in this box and you have to make
the best of it and you might say well i
don't want to be in a box like are you
so sure you don't want to be in a box a
box is a fortress the walls keep the
dragons away you want to be in a box
paradise is a walled garden
it's not a garden without walls it's got
walls right you have a house it has
walls you have a room it has walls
you don't want to be outside of a box
pick your damn box and then figure out
how to make it into a garden
well i want a box without walls no you
don't
it's nothing but snakes
what's happening people if you enjoyed
that then press here for the full
unedited episode and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
you